you know i've been saying this for a
long time and i think a lot of other
people who are critical of social media
not just facebook um have pointed out
that
the more um salacious the more angry the
more charged a tweet
a facebook post is
the more of a reaction it will get what
this does is
um it trains the algorithm that okay
this post we don't know what's in it
algorithms are not looking at what's in
it they're looking at what the outcome
is so they'll say okay here are the
thousand pieces of content show the
thousand pieces of content to a thousand
people
tell me or maybe even less like show to
100 people so now we got 100 000 people
have seen these thousands pieces of
content which one which 10 got the most
reaction comments likes shares okay
let's look at the words in there which
one got the most charged words which
one's got the longest responses which
one got the most follow-ups in other
words i replied on your post and then
you as the op the original poster did
you respond to me that would be like the
definition of a really vibrant uh
conversation happening i commented on
your post and you actually got back to
me so that ping pong thing could also be
a signal because if we are now in a
debate
and you're saying you know the clintons
are this murderous cobble of
maniacs and then you know i'm saying
trump is owned by the russians and now
we're going back and forth you know like
your aunt and your second cousin are
probably doing on your uh facebook with
the rest of the family watching in
horror and saying how are we gonna even
have thanksgiving this year like when
those two morons are going back and
forth talking through each other
that's a just incredible signal to the
algorithm because those people keep
coming back to facebook you know your
aunt or your cousin who's on facebook
all day long that's what this algorithm
is doing it's trying to make all of us
that addicted that's why the best thing
to do is to just turn off notifications
delete facebook delete twitter take a
break from it put a pause on it and
maybe use it only when you're at your
desktop and put a timer on it or put
yourself on a little timer so this is
truly devastating i think for facebook
that an insider has made the connection
between the research the explicit design
of the algorithm
and
the out financial outcome of course for
facebook
if this thing actually comes down to you
know brass tax
i think
what the uh people inside of facebook
are gonna say is well of course we want
people to use our product more what
company
uh does not want to uh delight their
customers and make the product better
we're we're looking at the signals if
people are using the product we will
look at how they're using it and make it
uh better that's our goal as a business
is to grow that's our mandate with our
shareholders are you saying that we
should
break our fiduciary responsibility to
shareholders and make and tank the
business because some people don't like
some conversations or some number of
people become addicted to it is there
are people who are addicted to
disneyland there are people who are
addicted to gambling it doesn't mean you
shut vegas down it doesn't mean you
don't allow them to buy
uh tickets to disney world and go every
day like there are people who will spend
a disproportion amount of their
personal
revenue and time and their personal
income on gambling on disneyland on
alcohol on cigarettes on whatever their
passion happens to be even if it's you
know i don't know uh
ordering expensive wine doesn't mean the
wine company is responsible that's going
to be their defense uh so back to the
wall street journal facebook files
article here is how facebook
quantitatively measured their new
algorithm
and this is a quote from that wall
street journal story facebook's solution
was to create a formula that measured
how much meaningful interaction of post
spark meaningfulness in quotes
then organize the news feed to encourage
as much of that as possible okay we get
it under an internal point system used
to measure its success a like was worth
one point a reaction we share without
text or reply to an invite was worth
five points okay
and a significant comment message
reshare or rsvp 30 points so that's
really interesting if you reshared it
with a comment or write a big message 30
times more than just a simple like which
is what i said earlier i uh i think
they're obviously looking for you to
spend more time and add more content if
you add content
and you share it with your group that is
the ultimate
way to get you more involved because
just even composing
that
response might take you 10 minutes right
and that's 10 more minutes they get of
the attention economy
additional multipliers were added
depending on whether the interaction was
between a members of a group friends or
strangers ah so
they know who your family are because
you say these are my family this is my
spouse these are my kids uh this is
somebody i work with these are friends i
think you can even say close friends on
on facebook so i'm assuming the
multiplier might be two x's if it's a
family member three exit if i said this
is a close friend right
so now what they want to do is really
get people who are close to each other
into these meaningful
um interactions with their friends and
family but what this did was
because they're not looking at the
qualitative they're just looking at the
behavior
that's like saying like how long did you
how long was thanksgiving how long was
that meal how long was your party and
it's like well the party might have gone
till 2 a.m and ended in a fist fight
because everybody got drunk and was
fighting over trump versus clinton or
biden or you know the the afghanistan
debacle
you know that doesn't mean it was mean
it might have been meaningful but it
also might have been dark and horrible
and scarring for life
it really is um interesting that um you
know these researchers pinpoint where
they believe this started going down um
and of course this is going to dovetail
with the january 6 activities
to be um a little bit neutral here
whatever happened at the capitol on
january 6th i know some of you feel it
was a protest although you feel it was
an insurrection i think for some people
it was a fun day out and a
like uh you know protest and uh you know
for other people they brought guns
so
you know if you bring guns to a protest
i think you're kind of tipping over into
crazy town uh and maybe insurrection
maybe it was in fact an insurrection for
that group of people while
the majority of people there it was a
protest uh or just a boondoggle and a
way to go and hang out with friends
right
people can go to the same event and have
two different experiences so
breaking news uh just informed that all
of facebook and instagram is down right
now brian krebs the famous uh security
expert has confirmed i'm reading his
tweet
from moments ago breaking news the dns
records that tell systems how to find
facebook and instagram got withdrawn
this morning from the global routing
tables
and you imagine working at facebook
right now when your email no longer
works and all your internal facebook
tools val
we don't know why this change was made
it could have been the result of an
internal system-wide change or update
that went
awry
it's all speculation at this point why
facebook is
in control over its dns records dns if
you don't know is the domain name system
um maybe they were hacked um that tends
to be what happens in these situations
it's either somebody with fat fingers
types in the wrong
you know uh routing records when they're
making a change um
and uh so bad day for facebook the
stock's also down five to six percent on
this news
uh the mark overall market i think is
down two to three percent so they're
down double the market uh which for a
leading company and a strong company
says something i don't think um
well let's talk in a minute about what
the outcome of all this is
we all know how hard it is to eat
healthy when you're grinding on product
sprints and trying to meet crazy
deadlines well now there's an innovative
food company trying to help
real good foods is one of the fastest
growing frozen food brands in the us
they're making nutritious foods more
accessible to improve human health and
they make all the food you love mexican
italian breakfast sandwiches pizzas and
more
everything is a hundred percent grain
free low in carbs high in protein and
best part made from real food
ingredients they are available in the
freezer section of costco walmart target
and 90 percent of grocery stores
nationwide when i found out about them i
went into my instacart i went out to
amazon they were everywhere and we've
been eating the pizza it's delicious
plus you can get them delivered same day
by instacart real good foods is healthy
convenient and tasty it's perfect for
any lifestyle plus part of their mission
is to support food banks across the us
and they have a goal of donating one
million nutritious meals nicely done
real good foods so go to
realgoodfoods.com and use the code twist
for 15 off
learn more and follow at real good foods
on social media or go
realgoodfoods.com and use that code
twist to get 15 off